les Yvelines terre de vélo terre de
parince pour la 15e année consécutive
une relation qui perdure la force du
département des hiines pour la course
cycliste c'est qu'on va y trouver des
bosses alors courte bien sûr mais mais
parfois raide et qu'il y a aussi le vent
et que en fonction des parcours traers
nous pouvons jouer avec le vent mais si
la continuité de ce que souhaite le
président du conseil départemental
Pierre Bédier il y a une vrai belle
valorisation de l'esprit sportif en
général et qui plus est avec ce parinis
vous ne pouvez pas imaginer la valeur
du territoire tel qu'il est conçu par
ASO le 3 mars 2024 le peloton de parign
s'élancera des Mureaux une première pour
la ville de 33000 habitants on est ravi
justement que le Conseil départemental a
choisi les Mureaux comme point de départ
d'autant plus que nous serons le point
de départ et je faire un petit clin
d'œil à l'activité économique des
Mureaux nous avons un lanceur arien 5
maintenant Aren 6 et c'est N qui allons
booster par Inis pas de cadeau pour les
coureurs 157 km m et de tours de circuit
une première étape souvent adressée aux
sprinters mais pour lesquels parfois les
puncherss trouvent leur bonheur la
dernière côte la côte d'Herbeville qui
est situé à 12 km de l'arrivée et là je
pense qu'il y a des choses à faire pour
les pour les coureurs elle sera précédée
cette course d'un sprint bonification
quelques kilomètres par avant à
montinville donc ça va lancer aussi la
course et des fois Parini se joue à la
seconde près donc ce qui est pris et
prix tradition oblige c'est une petite
commune qui accueille la deuxème étape
le 4 mars ce sera toiri 1400 habitants
qui sera ville départ une ligne de
départ devant le château de Toir au sein
même du zo c'est un peu la consécration
de notre rôle
touristique de la France mais aussi des
Yvelines et le fait que Pierre Bédier et
et ào et choisi toiri nous satisfait
avec une circonstance nous avons autant
d'habitants que d'animaux dans le eau le
pleloton prendra la route de lessonne en
passant par saint-arnou en Yveline pour
relier montargie ao donne rendez-vous
aux fans les 3 et 4 mars prochain pour
la 82e édition de la Course au
Soleil